Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
a summary more or less of authored by
we are in the chapter regarding the book
of fasting regarding upon whom is
fasting
obligated. ated upon whom is fasting
obligated?
And the author mentions
five points of criteria.
Every Muslim who is sane of the age of
puberty,
a resident and healthy.
We discussed yesterday morning,
alhamdulillah,
the rulings with respect to
what exactly is the definition of
illness and what exactly is meant by
someone who is healthy.
Today inshallah we will discuss the
fifth and final point of criteria and
that is al-im
person who is a resident. A resident is
the opposite of a traveler
alim.
When we look at the states of being with
respect to a person's travel,
the scholars, the jurists of Islam have
two general opinions with respect to
this issue.
Understanding this will help clarify a
lot of the things that many of us have
picked up tidbits of throughout our
lives over the years but still find it
difficult to kind of put it all together
and have a clear picture.
So what is a traveler? What is a
resident? And is there some kind of
middle ground? So the scholars of Islam
the fukah traditionally have
they are of two general opinions.
one which is the
when we look at the companions
and the
we find that they are pretty much upon
this first
view of travel and that is that a
person is either traveling
or not. They are either a traveler or a
resident. That's it. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says in the Quran,
he mentions two states of being. He
mentions the resident
and the traveler. He doesn't mention a
middle ground.
The second opinion which is a widely
accepted opinion amongst the scholars of
Islam and that is that there are three
categories actually. You have the
traveler,
you have the resident
but then you have this middle ground
which is a traveler resident.
A traveler resident.
What does that mean? a traveler
resident. Well, you've got someone who
is a resident. They live in their house
at their address or what have you.
You've got a traveler who is on his
camel. He's got a camp. He's setting up
tents. He is clearly traveling. He's on
the way. He's perhaps in the middle of
nowhere. He's between cities or towns or
villages.
But then you've got the resident
traveler.
Someone who is in an environment
that is the environment of a resident
but they themselves are still a
traveler. They're not intending to stay
there. Right? So you could imagine
someone who reaches you know another
city or another town or another country
that they are at. They're staying in a
hotel. They have all the amenities that
they would in their residence. However,
they don't have the intention of staying
in this place. They are a traveler, but
they are also a resident.
And because of this difference here in
viewing travel and residency,
the scholars
difference of opinion with respect to
the rulings of travel and the rulings of
a resident branch out from this. We are
going to stick with the first opinion
and that is that a person is either a
traveler or a resident. This is what
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions in
the Quran and when we look through the
sunnah of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam we look through all the days
all of his time in which he was
traveling in which he and his companions
were traveling in which he was going
from through the desert and at his
final destination wherever that may be.
we see that he was either a traveler or
a resident. So for instance in Tabuk he
spent 18 days. Those 18 days in Tabuk
they had set up an entire camp and they
were staying there
with the this great military that he
had with him at the time. It was the
biggest that the Muslims had ever had.
and he shortened his prayers throughout
the duration of his time in Tabuk.
We see that in the conquest of Mecca.
Now notice he's from Mecca. That's where
he's from. That used to be his home,
right? We see that he spent
roughly two weeks in Mecca at the
conquest of Mecca to stabilize
everything. And that's clearly a city.
It's clearly a town or or bigger than a
town, bigger than a village. It's a city
and it would otherwise have all the
amenities, maybe even better than what
he was used to in Medina. And on top of
that, he used to live there. However, he
shortened his prayers throughout the
duration of that time. And from these
incidents, we see the med of Abu Hanife
is 15 days. He bases this on these
occurrences
that in Tabuk in Mecca during the
conquest of Mecca 15 days he continued
to shorten his prayers. Therefore in the
med of Abihanif
and his four companions the Medab isn't
really just based on Abu Hanifh's
conclusions. It's actually five scholars
that make up the Hanfi Med. Abu Hanifh
is one of them. And
in that med the ex the accepted
opinion is 15 days. If a person is
going somewhere if they plan to stay
more than 15 days then they would not
shorten their prayers. But if they plan
to stay less than 15 days or
they are not certain of how long they
are going to stay, they will continue to
shorten their prayers.
And the other three, the mab of Im
Ahmed, Malik and I,
they say three days with their nights.
Some say four nights and three days or
three nights and four days.
And the same rule again, if the person
is staying for that long or is uncertain
as to how long they are staying, then
they will shorten their prayers.
Otherwise they will make full prayer as
a resident.
When we look at the companions,
we look at
the opinions of the great scholars of
the companions and even their actions.
We notice that they they narrate to us
incidents. they don't really narrate to
us
definitions right so for instance in
Bkari
Abbas
he says that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam stayed in tabuk for 18
days
and shortened his prayers therefore if
we go anywhere and intend to stay less
than 18 days we shorten our prayers if
we in intend to stay longer than we do
not. The question here is when he stayed
in Tabuk for 18 days.
Hypothetically, if he would have stayed
for 19 days, would he have not shortened
his prayers?
So, is there is is the number 18
special? Is that the special number that
it's it's 18? If it were 19, he would
have made his full prayers the entire
time. This is an incidental occurrence.
He stayed there for 18 days because
that's how long it took for him to
finish whatever business he was there to
do.
It's not necessarily because of the
number 18. If it were 19 or 25 or 17 or
12, the same set of circumstances are
still there, are still present. Correct.
At 18 days, if he would have stayed 19
days, would the circumstances have
changed in any meaningful way? No, they
would not have changed. Now Ib Abbz he
doesn't base this statement of his on
nothing. He based it on the most that he
saw from the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. So I'm going to stick with
whatever he did. Right? However, when we
look at it from the perspective of
what were the circumstances that made
him shorten his prayers, it was travel.
It wasn't the number of days
neither was it the distance.
This is another point of contention like
so anis and narrates that the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam set out on a
journey
and when he reached three
it was time for and he stopped and he
made his and he shortened his prayers.
How long? How far a distance is one for?
Anyone know?
Good. Three miles. Not kilos. M miles.
Yes. So one is three miles. Three is how
many miles? Nine. Okay. So Annis is not
narrating to us a definition of travel
of distance. Is he? He's narrating to us
an incident. This is something that
happened. He set out traveling. Vhor
came in at the time when he happened to
be 9 miles out of Medina. If he were 8
miles out of Medina
and
Vhor would have come in, would it have
changed the circumstances
in any meaningful way? No. It would be
the same set of circumstances.
Also, does it mean that
at 9 miles you're a traveler, but at 8
miles you're not a traveler? If we had a
caravan that was a mile long,
would there be a conceivable instance
where those at the front of the caravan
shorten their prayers and those at the
end of the caravan do not shorten their
prayers? Is nine miles a magic number?
Is it? That's not intended on itself.
What's intended are the circumstances.
This is what the majority of the
companions understood.
We see that Omar
went to Hashem.
Hashem, Syria, Dimash, and winters are
be brutal. There's snow. There's not a
lot of snow in Medina and and Mecca,
right, in the winter. And so as they
reached there and they arrived, winter
came in. Winter came in. It snowed.
Snowed him in. And so he remained there
shortening his prayers. Shortening his
prayers for how long?
Six months.
And some of the scholars have said,
well, he didn't know when he was going
to leave, right? He didn't know when he
was going to leave. So they say, "Maybe
tomorrow we'll leave. Maybe tomorrow
we'll leave." Until 6 months had
transpired. But does that sound
reasonable? Did Iban Omar look at all
these mountains of snow and imagine that
maybe tomorrow these mountains of snow
will be gone. They'll disappear and we
can leave tomorrow. Maybe maybe these
these mountains of snow will disappear.
He's there for the winter. He knows that
he's going to be there for months on
end. There's no
doubt about that. There are no qualms
with he or his entourage that they will
be there for the duration of the winter.
Therefore, what he understood
and what Bkari
inferred from this is that a person
is either a traveler or a resident. What
is the difference? The difference is if
a person lives at a particular place or
he does not. That's the only difference.
They are either in their home or they
are outside of their home. The amenities
is not really the issue. The difficulty
is not the issue. Sometimes people think
that to break your fast or to shorten
your prayers, you need to be having a
tough time when you're traveling because
that's the reason for shortening your
prayers. And that's not correct.
the level of difficulty is not the
reason that a person is is is not just
allowed but commanded to shorten his
prayers when he is traveling. It is the
state of being a traveler. That is what
is that is the that is the defining
factor here. When we look at all of this
he mentioned something that's very
interesting. He said whoever once after
researching this in dozens of pages
he c he says the following by the
meaning of his words. He says, "Hence,
for
[Silence]
Hassee.
He said, "Hence, whoever try, whoever
feels they want to play it safe,
right? When we talk about knowledge,
playing it safe is usually
a an issue of
the issue is not clear to me. So, I'm
going to play it safe. Otherwise, when a
person reaches a level of knowledge,
it's either yes or no. It's either right
or wrong. That's it. There's no safe.
These are rules, right? So he says
whoever feels uncomfortable and wants to
play it safe then it is three days with
their nights. However, whoever wants to
implement what is apparent from the
Quran and Sunnah and the actions of the
companions
and
then as long as the person is not living
permanently in that place, they are a
traveler. Based on all of these
evidences, we have instances of some of
the
who had shortened their prayers for up
to two years because he was appointed as
a judge against his will in a particular
land. He didn't want to be a judge. He
didn't want to live there. But he was
commanded to go by the Khalifa. And so
he shortened his prayers for the entire
2-year stint of being a judge there
because he had not intended to live
there ever. Right? And so these are
we start to see something starts to
clarify itself and that's what and what
is that? These are obviously extreme
instances but what they reflect is an
understanding that the companions and
tabain had and that is if a person
doesn't live somewhere
doesn't matter how comfortable their
stay or how long they are a traveler
there right now does that apply to like
students that are going to come here
from other countries and live here for
four years or six years or eight years
and become doctors and so on and so
forth. Of course not. Why? Because they
have
they have passports, they have
driver's licenses, they have a car, they
have an address, they have a house, they
have an apartment, they have a wife,
they have if that's not being a resident
somewhere, I'm not sure what being a
resident would be. However, if a person
were to go somewhere and be there for a
week, 2 weeks, someone goes for omrah,
they are a traveler during that time.
They shorten their prayers and they have
the the option of breaking their fast.
And we'll discuss what is better
tomorrow. Inshallah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. How are you?
Okay.